أجنبي
[موسيقى] [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى] أجنبي أجنبي أجنبي [
موسيقى] أجنبي أجنبي
أجنبي [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، فأنت تعلم من
المنظور الموضوعي أن الصين
تتعافى جزئيًا  نظرًا لأن
العام الماضي كان مغلقًا بشدة وهذا
العام عندما انفتح كل شيء منذ
نهاية العام الماضي،
عاد كل شيء إلى أه طبيعيًا،
القلق الرئيسي أه الشيء الرئيسي هو
التوقع
عندما يتوقع السوق أن تتعافى الصين
عند مستوى معين  السرعة إذا كان أداء الصين
أفضل من ذلك، فهذا يعتبر
صعوديًا، لذلك إذا لم يكن أداء الصين جيدًا
كما هو متوقع، فهو يعتبر
هبوطيًا، لذلك فالحقيقة هي أننا إذا
تحدثنا فقط عن التعافي الذي يتراوح
من الاقتصاد إلى قطاع الطاقة
للطلب على النفط على وجه الخصوص، الصين
تتعافى وسرعة
التعافي على ما يرام ولكن أداءها
أقل من
المتوقع في ظل الأداء مما كان متوقعًا مع ارتفاع
بعض أو العديد من المحللين أو السوق
في بداية العام، وهذا ما
حدث بالفعل  بعد
الربع الأول من العام أه، إنهم أم
أبريل ومايو وجزء من يونيو،
هناك نوع من التباطؤ في
التسليم المتوقع للاقتصاد الصيني
الطبيب المائي
[موسيقى]
أم نعم
بعد الناتج المحلي الإجمالي الرسمي لـ  4.5 في المائة
أولاً كما تعلمون أننا نرى أننا
نقيم أه رؤى السلع العالمية SMP
نقيم العام بأكمله أه انتعاش الصين سيكون نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
5.5،
وهذا يعني أن الصين بحاجة إلى
تقديم أفضل من 4.5 في المائة أه
للباقي  من العام حتى بالنسبة
للربع الثاني لأن الربع الأخير كان
نموًا أقل، لذلك حتى مع
الأداء الأقل من المتوقع في أبريل/نيسان ومايو/أيار،
قد لا يبدو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي الصيني سيئًا بسبب
أساس قابل للمقارنة، لذا
فإننا نتطلع إلى نمو بنسبة 5.5 بالمائة أه للعام بأكمله
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للصين
هذا سؤال جيد جدًا اه نعتقد
أن الطلب على النفط يتصرف بشكل
مختلف قليلاً وفي العام الماضي عندما
كان نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للصين ثلاثة في
المائة وهو بالفعل أدنى مستوى منذ
سنوات عديدة،
انخفض الطلب على النفط بمقدار النصف
مليون برميل يوميًا وهو ما لا يؤدي
فقط إلى انخفاض الانخفاض ولكن لديه
مليون برميل يوميًا لهذا
الأمر أه هذا العام نمو الطلب الصيني
على النفط أعلى مما أه
متوقع بسبب
الانخفاض الكبير والتنقل  كان أحد
الأسباب الرئيسية أه وراء الانخفاض
في العام الماضي لذلك نحن ننظر هذا العام
إلى ما يقرب من 900
ألف برميل يوميًا أو ما يقرب من
مليون إذا صيغت الأمر بهذه الطريقة
فنصف ذلك هو تعويض
الخسارة  العام الماضي
بشكل عام أتفق مع هذا النوع من
التقييم الذي أريد إضافته أولاً هو
عرض جيف أداء جيف فيو أفضل بكثير من
المجالات الأخرى في الصين وأماكن
أخرى في العالم. جمع
الثاني بشكل عام، فأنت تعرف بشكل عام فيما يتعلق
بقيادة الأشخاص والتنقل
موسم العطلات أه البنزين
وجنيفر على وجه الخصوص وكاثرين
تقومان بالجغرافيا كانت في حالة جيدة جدًا
كاثرين بخير نعم زيت الغاز والسلع
الأخرى الأخرى المرتبطة
بالأنشطة الاقتصادية الشاملة وخاصة
التصنيع والبناء وحتى
بشكل عام بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين ينفقون و  هذا
وذاك، نعم، هذا هو ما هو
أه هو أن القلق قد اكتسب،
ولهذا السبب تعلم أن الصينيين
ربما يفكرون في القيام بنوع من
طرح بعض
حزم التحفيز لتحفيز هذا الجزء
من جزء OE  الطلب أو الاقتصاد العام
هو
نعم، شكرًا لك أه نعم على
تحقيق الرقم
100000 برميل يوميًا أه الشيء المثير للاهتمام
هو كل ذلك بسبب ذلك كما تعلم
مقارنة إحصائية العام الماضي
كانت أدنى نقطة في الصين حيث كان الطلب على النفط أه في أبريل تقريبًا  قد يتعلق
الأمر بالنصف الأول من العام، أعلم
أننا لم ننتهي بعد، ونرى بشكل عام
أن الطلب الصيني على النفط ينمو
بحوالي دقيقة واحدة 1.1 مليون أو
حتى 1.2 مليون برميل يوميًا مقارنة بالعام
الماضي أه ببساطة لأن القاعدة كانت
منخفضة  وبالنسبة للنصف الثاني من العام،
نقول إن نمو العام والعام
قد يتباطأ إلى مثل أه
700000 برميل يوميًا، ضع الأمر على هذا النحو
منذ 50700000 برميل يوميًا
حيث نرى ما يقرب من 900000 برميل  كل
يوم يأتي من أنه نوع من التفاوت أه
لأنه في العام الماضي أه تعافى جزئيًا
بحلول نهاية العام ولكن
الضعف الشديد أه في الجزء المبكر من
العام الماضي
نرى بشكل عام الاتجاه المماثل،
النقطة المثيرة للاهتمام هي هذا
العام  تحدثنا عن هذا العام عندما ننتهي من
أه البنزين سيكون الطلب عليه على
الأرجح أعلى قليلاً من مستويات 2019 أه ما
قبله لكن الديزل سيظل
أقل من مستويات أه 2019 ومع ذلك
نرى أنه لا يزال هناك
مجال للصين للنمو  بضع
سنوات أخرى فيما يتعلق بالديزل أه بحلول عام 2024،
قد يكون الديزل على قدم المساواة مع عام 2019 ولكن
بشكل عام لا يوجد مجال أكبر
ربما نرى الذهاب إلى 25،
وهذا يتعلق الأمر بالبنزين الذي يحمل لفترة
أطول قليلاً، لذا بشكل عام نرى ما هو حولنا
لا يتم الطلب دائمًا على جزء المصهر بشكل عام
لأن الصين تحتاج إلى قدر كبير
من الطلب على النفط من أجل Pekka ومخزون الرسوم، لذا
على الرغم من أن الجزء المصهر من
الطلب على النفط في الصين ربما
لا يزيد عن 27 مثل عام 2026 لرؤية ذروة الطلبات،
شكرًا لك.  أعتقد أن هذا الأمر
مستمر منذ فترة ليس الآن فحسب، بل هو
بالطبع صعودًا وهبوطًا
قليلًا، لكنه ارتفع بشكل عام على مدار
السنوات العديدة الماضية ليس فقط الآن
منذ أن انخفضت أسعار النفط الوبائية بشكل
مؤكد  في الوقت الذي
اغتنمت فيه الصين الفرص لبناء
المخزون على مدى السنوات العديدة الماضية، ولكن عندما يحين الوقت الذي كان هناك فيه
ارتفاع في الأسعار
وقرارات تجارية أخرى
اتخذتها الشركات الفردية، فإنها تقوم
أيضًا بالسحب مباشرة عندما  السعر
يرتفع بسرعة كما أنهم يحاولون أيضًا
الاستفادة من المخزون المنخفض أه أه من
المخزون الأقل تكلفة ولكن بشكل عام على
حق أه ربما تكون الصين قد راكمت
ما يكفي على الأقل في الوقت الحالي أو ربما لا
يكفي ولكن كمية كبيرة من
مخزون النفط  احتياطيات
السنوات العديدة الماضية،
صحيح كما تعلمون
أننا نرى هذا العام وجزءًا من
العام المقبل أن الطلب على النفط مدفوع من حيث
الوصول إلى شرق آسيا أه آسيا
تعني الصين ولكن أيضًا تضيف جنوب آسيا
وجنوب شرق آسيا لذلك نرى آسيا بما في ذلك
الصين  يقود هذا العام ما يقرب من 70
بالمائة من نمو الطلب على النفط البالغ 2 مليون برميل يوميًا الذي
نراه لعام
2023، لذا فإن مليوني برميل يوميًا
نراها لهذا العام والعام المقبل
معتدلة قليلاً ولكنها لا تزال 1.9
مليون برميل يوميًا حتى  على الرغم من أن
دور آسيا أقل قليلاً،
إلا
أننا نرى أنه نظرًا لبعض التحسن
في الاقتصاد العالمي بعد عام 2023، فإننا نرى
نوعًا من التحسن في الطلب
في دول مثل الولايات المتحدة ومنطقة
مثل أوروبا الغربية، لذا ستتحسن تلك المناطق
بشكل عام،
نرى 1.9 مليون برميل يوميًا من
نمو الطلب في عام 2024.
نشعر أن أسعار سوق الموظفين
مدفوعة بالأساسيات ومعنويات السوق،
لذا فإن معنويات السوق
تهيمن بشكل أو بآخر، نحن الآن
في منعطف حرج  أه لأن
الربع الرابع من العام عادةً ما
يكون فيه نمو أقل للطلب على مستوى العالم بينما يتم
بناء العرض كالمعتاد والآن
ننتقل إلى الصيف، نرى
أن السوق بشكل أساسي
يتشدد ولكن السوق لا
يناسب السوق  لا يبحث عن
إشارات لذلك حتى ترى الأسواق
تشديدًا حقيقيًا
للمخزون العالمي السوق تبحث عن الأشياء
التي أه بطريقة مختلفة عندما تكون هناك
مشكلات في العرض ثم أي علامة
على أه الأسبوع الشاهد الاقتصادي
الاقتصاد وإرسال الإشارة إلى
السوق أعتقد حاليًا أن هذا
تأثير ولكننا نشعر أن
الأساسيات مشدودة نحو
يوليو وأغسطس الآن طوال العام وليس قرب
نهاية العام لأنه في نهاية
العام أه قد يخسر المخزون  سنرتفع
مرة أخرى
بحلول نهاية
العام ولكن في يوليو وأغسطس وسبتمبر
سنرى ربما الاختبار لنرى أن
أسعار النفط قد ترتفع مرة أخرى في
الخارج
خلال الشهرين أو الثلاثة أشهر القادمة في ضوء
تحليلنا الذي نرى فيه المخزون
نرى أنه على
أساس المتوسط ​​الشهري نرى أن
العلامة التجارية المؤرخة قد تعود إلى 85
دولارًا أو أكثر مثل 86 87 دولارًا في
الأشهر المقبلة ولكنها ستتراجع
نحو 80 إلى 83 دولارًا تقريبًا بحلول نهاية
العام و  في العام المقبل ربما
تلقينا تكرارًا مثل أسبوع في
الربع الأول ونحصل على أه
نتحول في بداية
الربع الثاني ثم في الصيف لذا في
المتوسط ​​نرى أنه في العام التالي أه
أسعار النفط تبلغ حوالي
أو 84 تقريبًا  من المثير للدهشة أن هذا هو
نفس هذا العام تقريبًا، لذا فهو
أكثر أو أقل من 80 23 24 متوسط ​​العلامة التجارية المؤرخة الذي
تعرفه بخلاف
متوسط ​​التقلب الذي يبلغ حوالي 84 85 ربما
84 دولارًا في المتوسط ​​لكلا العامين
وهذا أقل من متوسط ​​101  العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
أجنبية
[موسيقى]